dès sa sortie de prison patrick dils est
effectivement rendus dans un lieu tenu
secret pour retrouver sa famille et ses
amis des moments très forts qu'il
espérait vivre depuis des années il a
accepté de se confier à nous par
téléphone de nous faire part de son
émotion en écoute j'ai soufflé et puis
on fait tous regardés il ya eu quelques
larmes de lâcher et puis la joie d'être
ensemble
j'ai passé un moment très simple mais ô
combien important et ô combien magique
je dirai pas ce que ça n'a rien à voir
avec le contexte d'un parloir ça n'a
rien à voir avec l'univers carcéral
c'est tous les quatre et libre la
liberté dans lequel produit simplement a
peur parce que ben départ je la connais
pas je vais découvrir demain je sais pas
son point est ce qu'il mouille vraiment
le bon mais un peu via une naissance
donc quelque part c'est non rien ne me
fait peur je vais apprendre et puis je
serais passé les rangs on ne peut pas
oublier 15 ans et je ne veux pas oublier
cycle 1 année parce qu'elles sont
lourdes de conséquences
et je vais surtout qu'une telle erreur
ne se reproduise jamais dans le futur
j'aurais amis je vais mener un combat
pour les indices et puis j'ai
l'intention de faire beaucoup de choses
à ce niveau là j'ai pas mal de projets
et je ne peux pas les nouveaux patrick
dils en prise avec un cas aussi terrible
qu'elle vient ça c'est hors de question
pour les questions